hello everyone I just came back from a
nice swim and a nice cold beer and here
it is the game you have all requested
it's Maxie Murphy Oleg Rob versus the
wild card Richard report we are still at
day one of the st. Lewis reppin and
blitz tournament without further ado
let's just enjoy the game as it's really
really a nice game
so MVL opens with E for and a report
plays East 6 so the French defense
against the Frenchmen with d4 d5
and E 5 Maxime goes for the advanced
variation and c5 is the most common
reply as white just well maybe over
advanced this pawn central you want to
attack his central pawn with your seat
bond with c3 defending the center and
Knight to c6 black develops while still
attacking the center whiten does the
same developing while defending the
center and Queen to b6 attacking once
again also preventing Bishop to e3 as
the Queen now also attacks the B to bond
with a 3 and here is one of the one of
the cases where it's okay to push c4
because the white played a three so the
point is no longer an a3 white cannot
play b3 to attack well your pawn chain
or you know if you've read a chess book
or two you will often read that chess
principles don't like moves like c4 but
in this case it works with Knight B to
d2 now again covering the B 3 squared b3
once again an option and now a report
prevents it with Knight to a5 guarding
the be 3 square and here Maxime says
okay no longer do I control b3 let's
just continue development g3 preparing
to develop the light square bishop with
Bishop to d7 by report and now h4 with
queenside castle and now comes the shock
to h3 and here King to be a just getting
the King out of this diagonal you don't
want it there for for you know for the
rest of the game and also it may be
freeze the rook for the CH the CA square
for the rook with castles by Robert and
now comes h6 a sort of a maxim and h6 by
reporter report now maybe with ideas of
pushing g5 not at the moment as it still
doesn't work but maybe in the future as
why did Castle kingside so maybe you
want to start an Ice King side attack
with rook to e1 by Maxime and now Knight
to e7 g5 doesn't work seems like a nice
idea but h5 prevents any ideas black
happened on the Kings side and you will
no longer be able to push anything for
anything here
so after lucky one we have Knight to e7
by Robert and now comes Luke the b1
again keeping an eye on the B 3 square
and not Knight to c8 preparing to
Riemann over the night and here Knight
to f1
Maxime does the same if B 3 now it's not
all that great because for example if
pawn captures Knight captures Knight
captures Queen captures on b3 and let's
see you trade everything captures
captures white will be left with a
isolated a pond and also with a weak
backwards c3 pawn as the black covers
the c-4 square black can just play
Knight b6 with further control of c4
just blockade the pawn gave his rooks
over here Luke CH rook c6 get the other
Brooke over to c8 and white will have a
hard time defending his backward C pawn
so here we have night 2 f1 by Maxime and
now Queen back to c7 we have 8 a freeing
the b6 square for blacks night with h5
maxime grabbing more space on the King
side and now Knight the b6 with Bishop
d3 developing the bishop and now Bishop
a4 attacking Mac seems Queen Queen to e2
and now Bishop to e7 preparing to get
the other look into the game with Knight
3 2 h 2 preparing f4 Maxime wants to
grab more space maybe even push f5 we
have Queen to d7 and now f4 and now a
rapper doesn't want to meet f5 anytime
soon so he pushes g6 with Bishop back to
f2 and the now comes rook D to G 8 and
now if you look at this position it's a
really closed structure look at the
center here there's nothing you know
getting past this central pawn structure
but if it's anyone who's who seems to be
attacking it seems to be black even
though I can somehow open up files in
front of the White King he already has
the both of his rooks here and it could
get ugly for Maxine we have Knights to
e3 by Maxine
and not night back the c6 with King - h1
getting the King away from the G file
that might open up soon and Bishop back
to d8 and now H captures and g6 with F
captors and g6 and now Queen to g4 so
here even though the position was
completely closed Maxime finds a way to
attack blacks position pressuring the g6
pawn will not currently can it be
captured as a rogue defensive but
pressuring the e6 pawn but here Robert
finds a beautiful way is how to defend
it he plays Queen to h7 and now what's
the idea again the e6 pawn be captured
there are the answer is no because if
Queen captures then you get Knight
captures on d4 and now after C captures
on d4 this Bishop comes to d7 just
attacking the Queen Queen d6 check the
shot blocks and now you have to move the
Queen and black wins back the piece
Bishop captures on h3 you got your piece
back and you're gonna enjoy a better
position
so here Maxime gets an idea he plays b3
and this is one move that you can only
find if you've calculated the previous
variation the Queen captures and
instance doesn't work because captures
captures captures and then Bishop d7
so play b3 and now of course if Bishop
captures then you can capture on e6 the
bishop can no longer go back so Robert
says okay I'm just gonna capture with
the pawn he plays a C capture son b3 but
now maxime does something well excellent
he created here he just wanted to get
this point to b3 so he can capture it
later here he plays Queen captures and
he's six now I know what you're thinking
how does b3 and C captors and b3 allow
him to play Queen captures on a6 now
well the idea is next and this is
exactly why I used this quote above the
board as it perfectly illustrates well
Mac seems play here with Knight captures
on d4 as in the variation that we've
just shown see captures on d4 and Bishop
to d7 so what what did Maxine have in
mind here if he moves the Queen Queen d6
check we get Bishop c7 it's the same
idea but here maxime actually played the
Queen captures on d7 he already has a
piece as black captured on the
and now he grabs another phone another
one and sacrifices his queen so Robert
has very little to say here he has the
captured we have night captures and the
now comes route capture Sun be three so
the inclusion of b3 was so Maxime can
sacrifice the Queen and open up the B
file for his rooks maybe next he can
play rook idea roof to be one maybe he
can start pushing his a pawn create an
attack against the black King s he still
has his bishop pair if I could say it in
French I would Knights the beasts X
blocking the rooks file and now a for
preparing a five and here if you don't
want to lose this point you have to
capture the a4 pawn this is what Robert
does with Knight captures an a4 and now
Knight captures on d5 and now well
Maxine has two pieces for the Queen but
if Robert wants to get anything out of
the position his real strengths are are
the two rooks I'm the White King so he
has to open up the position and activate
the rooks if he doesn't do that he's
already lost so he starts with the g5
but Maxime of course wants to close the
position so he pushes f5 we have G for
my report and now Bishop back to g2 with
Knight b6 going for a trade here but
Maxime just Marie moves the knight
Knight to III to use it for later
with 85 preparing h4 but here we have f6
and already okay you're down a queen but
your central pawn pawn structure is
really starting to look great here sorry
about the slow coloring it's really not
functioning on my laptop and a report
continues his push on the Kings side
with h4 and now just king g1 and here
the problem is if you open up the H file
after Bishop captures and g3 you don't
have anything here
White's a bishop pair is really insane
and well e six is coming and you have no
ways of breaking through here the bishop
is just gonna keep an eye on the h2
square and you're you're not gonna be
able to break through here and in a
rapid game keeping an eye on such a such
a powerful pawn Center is not possible
so after Kings you want with Bishop to
c7 and now we have ripped the c1 just
putting the rook on a nice open C file
Queen to d7 attacking the d4 pawn
now look the D 1 by Maxine here a report
losing time decides to maybe it maybe
now he should capture on G 3 so he does
we have H captures and G 3 Bishop
captures and jittery and now comes Luke
2 H 3 a very nice idea where if you
capture the rook which which is possible
but then after this G captures on h3 you
have a lots to defend your G 3 bishop is
under attack you have to defend at night
H 1 then H 2 comes you will also open a
BH file and well a Queen and the rook
maybe you will have some hard time
defending as your king is not wide open
so this is not something you want to do
and it's not what MV L did MV L played
night H 2 F 1 and it's the best move in
the position because if you play
something like Knight e to F 1 seems
like it's the same and maybe even better
as you can never cross the H 2 square as
the bishop defends it it doesn't work
because here you have rook captures rook
sorry rook captures so let's say rook
captures and G 3 and now Bishop captures
on e5 because now you cannot capture the
Queen can will capture the rook and well
you just lost your pawn Center which was
your your trump card in the position so
here Maxime goes night H 2 F 1 and now
the same idea doesn't work because after
the same variation in Bishop captures in
d5 you will not be able to capture on D
1 as the knight from e3 guards the rook
that's the idea
so after Luke H 3 night H 2 F 1 by
Maxime and now rook back to h5 no longer
is a report keeping this rook on H 3
free for grabs and now comes Luke the C
3 preparing the D other group to come to
the C file and you know wreak havoc so
to say we have ripped the c8 defending
and the now comes rook d c1 and here
well it's very hard to find the move no
active move can be found here
so Queen captures on d4 is played you
just grab the pawn but what can black do
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the Maxine's idea in this
position as it's is it's a very nice
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you have just
utilize your Bishop air from hell to
perfection and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy a show Bishop captures on c7
if you found east sex it's not the same
idea because after Bishop captures and
g3 you don't have Ruka fate mate as the
night guards the rook here so that's not
possible
so rook captures in c7 first rook
captures and now E six unleashing the
bishop here and now there's very little
black can do here here if you defend it
with Knight a eight it's just e seven
you're threatening to win a queen after
Queen d7 defending rook to d1 attacking
the Queen and after the Queen moves
wherever just rugged e8 and that's game
over
there's no recovering from this so after
East six rapidset okay rook c5 just
defending but now rook captures on c5 e
seven was even better here because after
each seven is the game over now you can
either try prevail you can't prevent a
queen because if you move the Queen to
d7 like in that line then you lose the
rook you the Queen has to be here to
keep an eye on the rook so you can play
role capture serum but then you get a
queen into the game after night c8 you
just play f7 you're gonna get another
Queen into the game it is unplayable so
we have route captures on c5 it's a
similar idea but it leaves the report
with one more defensive resource with
Queen captures on c5 and now e seven but
now this diagonal is free so Queen to h5
report immediately finds it and now the
queening square is protected so maxime
has to find another way how to do it he
finds Knight f5 he tries to sacrifice
the night so he can get the queening
square free and of course it's it's a
nice idea but it doesn't work
unfortunately for Maxime but it's a
rapid game so it might work feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only defensive idea that works here for
black but I warn you if you try to do it
it's a really insane you know defensive
sorcery line so I don't know maybe we
want to try and do it for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
you are a true engine sorcerer and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Knight to d7 a report missed this
move he played nice to see it and it
seems like it's the same idea but it's
not we're gonna show why ninety seven
works
because it threatens the capture on f6
while defending this square for example
and now if you play Knight g7 which
seems like an idea you're attacking the
Queen and also threatening to get
another Queen into the game
Queen c5 is the idea and now after
Bishop f2 blocking and attacking the
Queen now you play Knight captures on f6
and you've defended but still it's
impossible for a human in a rapid game
to find this because after Bishop
captures on c5 rook captures on c5 now
you get a queen into the game and now
you get captures captures and still it's
a rook against three pieces but there's
no stopping the a pawn it's just insane
I was actually just kidding you know if
you wanted to find it no one can find
this Bishop if for just trying to get
the pieces how to defend it for you
there's no stopping the pawn if Knight
here threatening Knight check to pick up
the rope you just play route b5 Bishop
to d5 is now possible covering the a2
square but it doesn't matter a3 and once
white tries to get the other night into
the game Ruby - you attack the knight
and the pawn here if you attack the rook
and the point you would 94 you just
advance the eight pawn you don't care
about the rook you're getting a queen
and if you try something like well
Knight fe4 or something like that
the don't really know defending the
knight a2 is coming now you have to give
up the bishop and we're only two nights
without pawns it's white we'll have to
be careful not to blunder something here
so this is this is the idea after Knight
to a5 Knight to d7 could have saved the
game for rapper but he played night c8
and it's a different idea because it
allows Maxime the the winning move so
the winning move well feel free to pause
the video even now and try to find it
and it but it's really crazy if you
found that you are truly like you know a
monster wizard sorcerer engine user from
hell I don't know how to even support it
but Maxime played it Knight e3 and now
it's a now it's clear Knight to d5 is
coming and there's no saving the rook
and c7 and this could all have been
prevented if this Knight came to d7
instead of here if the knight was on d7
93 by white would not be possible
Knight captures nf6 would come and white
it doesn't have 95 as the night from f6
covers d5 so this is just insane
so a report now tried Queen to g6 hoping
to meet 95 with Queen captures on f5
also keeping around the f6 pawn but it
doesn't work Knight to d5 now defense f6
there's nothing to do here best Bishop
captures is coming so he grabbed the
night but now Bishop captures on c7 and
it was in this position that Richard
report resigned the game on move 50 as
there is nothing more to do here
once you make a move King it is the only
move you're getting eh Queen so you grab
Queen into the game you can't get the
Queen away from the defense of the
Knight Queen captures here will be made
you can give one check when do one check
but after Bishop blocks you have to
return keep an eye on the night here and
now pretty much everything wins for
white you can push up 7 bring another
Queen into the game there's nothing to
do here if you push g3 but can just
capture it there is no counter play here
so really an insane game by Maxine and
the report you know it always takes two
to create a brilliancy but definitely
the the top game from day one so I do
hope you enjoy enjoyed it as well pretty
much all of you have suggested that
story took so long for me to upload it
but you know I am you know enjoying my
swims and ended a nice cold beer yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon covering the same to
its rapid event
continuing the capablanca saga when I
return to my home town and checking up
on your suggestions as usual thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day